i'm going to talk about the benefits of something
called tudca okay what does it stand for well it's
a very very long name for a very specific bile
acid and this type of bile acid has been found
to be present in bearers now they used
to kill a lot of bears just for this bile
because it was so valuable um but now
they made it synthetically which seems
to work pretty good and um they don't have to
kill the bears anymore which is a good thing
but this treatment using this very specific bile
acid has been used for hundreds of years in asia
it's been used by the american indians for
various purposes it's used for treating gallstones
because a gallstone is a lack of bile and it's a
super concentrated cholesterol stone that can be
dissolved when you add more bile also this type of
bile acid is used for liver cirrhosis because it
inhibits fibrosis which is scarring of the liver
so anyway it's a really great ingredient for
a lot of different things especially if
you tried everything and nothing's worked
try this because it's very very effective
at a lot of different conditions
let's just talk about what it can do it can help
you thin your bile many people have a situation
where their bile is too thick and they might
not develop a stone but they have a lot of pain
in the right lower quadrant of their abdomen so
they have a lot of congestion bloating and that
can create pancreatitis it can create a whole
bunch of issues because the bile then backs up
into the liver and it's a detergent so it's very
very irritating to the liver tissue and that can
cause pain and shoot up to your right shoulder
blade and up to the neck and create headaches
create a whole bunch of problems now also realize
that where the liver is located on the right side
when it gets backed up it can put pressure
on the heart it can put pressure on your
lungs so it can affect breathing it
can affect the heart it can create
palpitations and even arrhythmias by having
the liver being a little bit too swollen
and because there's just not enough space in that
area so there's a lot of benefits to the heart
by taking this tudca now some of you are gonna
ask me um what type of brand should i buy whatever
well i'm not gonna recommend a certain brand
that's up to you to do that research because i
can't get involved with um trying to figure out
what the quality is and regulate them because
if i recommend a certain product and then they
change the formula so you just have to do your
own research on that but i recommend the dosage
to start out if you have a major problem take two
on an empty stomach in the morning and take
two in the afternoon and empty stomach but
if you take it with food it's going to help you
digest the food all right number two there's been
a lot of research in the past in ongoing research
on the eyes on retinal degenerative disease
on various problems with the eye on improving
visual acuity why because bile helps you break
down and absorb vitamin a and there's a lot
of other reasons why it helps the eye as well
number three it's been shown to improve
symptoms of parkinson's disease why because
it's neuroprotective it seems to help the neurons
in your brain it also has shown positive effects
on alf that is a certain autoimmune disease
okay so if you have als you should be taking
cut cup number five it's shown benefits
of not just preventing a stroke but also
repairing the damage of a stroke because
it's neural protective in your brain
all right number six it's it's good for
spasms number seven it can reduce fevers
number eight it can improve your eyesight which
i mentioned previously number nine it prevents
something called apoptosis which is program
cell death caused by a stressed mitochondria
so in other words tutka helps to stabilize
the mitochondria and it prevents this
program cell death very very powerful number 10 it
has very good anti-inflammatory effects especially
of the liver so if you have any liver problem like
cirrhosis hepatitis or or a fatty liver this would
be a good thing to take number 11 it can decrease
fibrosis which is very cool number 12. it protects
the brain i already mentioned that and it can
decrease plaquing of those beta amyloid plaques
in the brain very cool 13 it can support insulin
sensitivity so if you have insulin resistance it
can help with that condition it can make insulin
more sensitive so for a diabetic it's really good
stuff number 14 it supports the gut lining if you
have leaky gut or there's some permeability issues
where there's food that's getting into the pores
of your intestine this would be a good thing to
support that condition especially if you have like
inflammation of the colon itself and number 15 it
helps protect the kidney so as you can see it does
a lot of things and i just scratched the surface
so anyway i just wanted to bring your awareness up
of this great tool in helping various conditions
i've mentioned it in other videos but i just
wanted to create a separate video just on this
one very cool bile acid hey before you go
real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today